everything you do is amazing but
euphoria has really touched the soul of
sort of like pop culture and the
cultural zeitgeist how has it been to be
a part of something like that I just
feel very lucky that's really all I
always kind of say it's just that I just
felt lucky to be able to tell Bruce
story and and Sam story and yeah I don't
know I just feel like it just felt like
something special as I was doing it and
I and I'm just grateful that people have
been able to connect to it the way they
have and the fact what you pulled out in
in this performance though I don't know
if a lot of people would have thought
you could you really need to fight
expectations do you feel that for
yourself like you really at its dark you
know it's like it's a personal thing you
know it's if I try to take the world out
of it and it's not about proving
anything to the world but it's really
about getting better as an artist and
and being more and in touch with where I
can go and how I can do it I just try to
kind of keep it internal because that's
a much happier place to work from when
you're working just to really just to
prove yourself that you can do it you
know I know this year in Hollywood I was
gluing stuff to my face because I wanted
up that euphoria I you know everyone
wants to copy it and we're are there
right we're at the Critics Choice Awards
so I'm asking everyone to be their own
worst critic what is the thing that you
did that you hated that you bombed that
you were like this is this is the worst
like to fit in general people are like I
was the first dead body on CSI I was on
like young and the restless' and I had
to like fake cry my own anything that
exciting I mean I've definitely had some
of my own like I've had my own
red-carpet moments that I
listen I wouldn't take it back though
because you gotta live in you're looking
you gotta learn you know and that's okay
okay tell me about this look this is
one-of-a-kind this is in absolutely
insane I was like you the fool Tom Ford
number no one's actually really cool I I
saw it on the runway and me and la
obviously thought it was sick and
amazing and it was really cool because
they were actually able to scan and mold
my own body so it fits me the right way
so it's pretty cool yeah it was like it
was very science tech situation going on
so I was I was a very great
one-of-a-kind
[Music]